v en est plus agile pour le groupe est
républicain merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des finances au projet de loi
de finances pour 2016 était attendu il
est inattendu inattendue parce que c'est
une nouvelle fois un rendez vous manqué
vous parliez il ya quelques minutes
monsieur le ministre d'un budget sérieux
et solide
permettez moi d'en douter il est avant
tout dépourvu d'ambition ce qui est la
marque d'un immobilisme pernicieux ex
anxiogène le constat est pourtant
partagé le déficit public à 3 3% reste
hypothétique
tandis que la réduction du déficit reste
loin d'être acquise en réalité votre
politique est celle du parapluie que
vous prêtez quand il fait beau et que
vous reprenez quand il pleut vous faites
des prévisions de croissance alors que
celle ci est instable en raison de la
volatilité des marchés financiers et du
ralentissement du commerce mondial
finalement la raison principale de ce
projet de loi de finances qui vous sert
à mettre la poussière sous le tapis
c'est que vous renoncez vous renoncer
une nouvelle fois vous attaquer aux
véritables sujets tels le poids
étouffant des prélèvements le poids
étouffant des dépenses publiques et une
réforme de fond de notre système d'état
providence votre plan d'économies de 16
milliards d'euros demeure floue et vous
vous défausser notamment sur les
collectivités locales
ce qui est incontestable la rapporteur
général du budget
dans son rapport sur le projet de loi de
finances estime que sur les 16 milliards
d'euros d'économies prévues un peu plus
de 4 milliards restent non documentées
par des mesures concrètes
ce qui pose ce qui pose la vraie
question de la crédibilité de votre
texte votre programme de baisses
d'impôts comporte un risque par ailleurs
non dissimulée d' inégalité devant
l'impôt
deux chiffres en 2012 plus de 52 % des
foyers fiscaux français payé l'impôt sur
le revenu contre estimé en 2016 46 %
alors que dans le même temps dans le
même temps l'impôt sur le revenu a
augmenté de 20 milliards 20 milliards
d'euros
en conclusion monsieur le ministre
pourquoi présentez-vous un projet de loi
de finances en place des imams
la parole est à monsieur le ministre des
finances et des comptes publics m merci
madame la présidente monsieur débuter
vraiment nouvelle j nous allons pouvoir
discuter débattre de ce projet de loi de
finances au cours des heures et des
jours qui viennent ça nous permettra
point par point de pouvoir répondre à
l'ensemble des questions qui sont les
vôtres
enfin quelques commentaires malgré tout
vous trouvez que nos hypothèses de
croissance sont des hypothèses trop
optimistes vous le disiez l'année
dernière nous respectons cette année les
hypothèses qui étaient les nôtres les
hypothèses que vous trouvez trop
optimistes ce sont très exactement celle
que l'ensemble des observateurs le fonds
monétaire international lancé des oeufs
la commission européenne considère comme
réaliste
nous avons donc un budget solide et
réaliste sur lequel nous fondons ensuite
un certain nombre de dépenses et un
certain nombre de recettes
quelques mots sur les recettes madame
vous venez de nous dire en 2012 il y
avait 52 % de français qui votent l
impôt qui veulent payer l'impôt pardon
et il ya 46 % de français aujourd'hui
combien y avait-il de foyers qui en 2007
paient l'impôt sur le revenu combien
rien avait-il 46%
que s'est il passé entre 2007 avec cette
majorité comme avec nous pour des
raisons qu'ils voulaient faire en sorte
quand on lutte contre les déficits ça a
été une augmentation considérable et
souvent injuste avec vos propres mesures
de l'impôt sur le revenu payés par les
français les plus modestes ce que nous
faisons c'est de rendre aux français les
plus modestes les impôts que vous leur
avez fait payer et qu'ils doivent
aujourd'hui pouvoir enfin récupérer
c'est ça aussi madame la justice fiscale
alors un mot enfin sur les dépenses à
chaque fois et on va encore le vérifier
que nous proposons de faire une économie
vous venez encore d'en parler à propos
des collectivités locales vous êtes
contre 100% des économies vous êtes
content et au même moment
vous nous dites ou faites pas assez
d'économies il faut faire 150 milliards
d'économies alors expliquez moi comment
vous faites c'est du n'importe quoi de
votre merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à m